the Joe Rogan experience I'm hoping that
Burt and Tom both say that we cheated
already because we're good dude the
first year I'll take everybody to dinner
someone somebody said Kent bucho they
were like but you are cheating other
guys do tell me right now if is cheating
cuz I'm done yeah it's cool I'm out one
of the great things about our contest is
there's no real ramifications other than
talking [ __ ] you know like Burt came in
last but what happened to him what
happened to him nothing nothing we just
talk we can all I do is talk [ __ ] and
then dealt with no repercussions we all
knew that we couldn't lose to Burt that
was those a massive motivating factor
for everyone including Tom and when Tom
came back and he ran 13th [ __ ] he was
done on injury he was done he's sick he
got really sick yeah yeah he came back
and the day back he ran 13 [ __ ] miles
to try that I catch up and he did catch
I did catch up and pass him bro is there
about this year
no the belt stays well I feel like
there's no belt because it's not a
competition this year this is the
problem the pram we're gonna explain
this folks on the sober October podcast
which is right after this but the
problem is we none of us have the time
for the competition I can't go crazy why
what's different from this year to last
year
I'm too busy is questioned yes is your
schedule not exactly the same as it was
last year more podcast for sure are you
doing more podcast yeah more podcasts
and other various activities outside of
the podcast and then the heat that I
took from my family like my kids didn't
see me for a month yeah that's why I
thought I had some sort of chance
because hats to be home but I forgot
that you guys also have gyms in your
home yeah have a full gym I had that
24-hour gym I would go to yeah on the
way home from so that's where I got some
nice points yeah that's a good move well
you when you first figured out that you
could just watch a movie in that that
distracts you enough to do cardio and
you can get some cucumbers okay
that's pretty smart because that does
distract the [ __ ] out of you it makes it
way easier yeah I would just post my
workout would just be the movie that I
watched dude I'm already high from the
cigar I feel yeah right I feel like
we're out
I'm just hoping Tom and Burt come in
know we're doing the cigars as well on
the platform together first place let's
have a dance-off for first place
dance-off when he was talking to
dance-off I was like he's just gonna
take his pants off I know what he's
gonna do and then he did that video and
that's exactly that was a big jaded
[ __ ] first two years in her comedy
when he was said he was terrible he
would do the pants off thing didn't well
and now it's worth doing now 28 years in
the comedy should stop but people get
mouthy if he doesn't take his shirt off
I know she's a trap I would be mad too
if I want to see Bert Kreischer his
final time doing stand-up in my city
what smell
Ben is loud it's stuff like so [ __ ]
what tornado in here does it I can hear
it through the headphones is it cause
we're talking cigars oh yeah I know damn
I got a head rush off the cigar that's
what I'm saying we're high dude what
cheating we're [ __ ] for sure cheating
I don't know what I'm gonna do dude this
whole [ __ ] the Yankees are going all
the way I'm gonna have to follow your
Yankee games well right now like
elevated levels of nicotine we should be
doing so bombed October we really should
be going for it the other way those guys
into it let's just switch it up you guys
some whisky meals really go hard YUM
mushrooms every other day yeah
[Applause]